but we have to get to our big reporter
on the nba campus
and that is my guy chris haynes he's
been living there for a while and i need
to check up on him
chris a lot of people are talking about
the anonymous tip
hotline for violations how active has it
been
and really who has been calling i need
the information
well sources have told me that hotline
has been used
just a handful of times and i was told
it's been a mixture
of players as well as staff members and
this was expected this is not alarm at
all this is expected when you get this
amount of
players on campus at one time so the
league anticipated
you know this hotline being ringed a few
times is not alarming
but that has been the case thus far
all right i did hear that there was a
disturbance complaint in one of the
hotels though what was that about
well last week during the quarantine
period
the hotel that the miami heat was
staying at a security guard
received a complaint of disturbance
there was a loud thumping going on so
sources told me that the security guard
went over to investigate found the room
knocked on the room and who opened the
door it was miami heat for
jimmy butler dressed in sweat with a
practice gear on from head to toe
he was dribbling a basketball throughout
throughout his room the whole time
and so even during the quarantine period
jimmy butler was still
getting his practice sessions in
good i was worried there might be some
form of entanglement
okay when it comes to the top seed in
the west the lakers
we know that rondo has left the campus
with a broken thumb avery bradley
already not going to be there
but you're hearing that lebron is having
people off the court
absent as well what's the deal with that
well lebron is switching things up he on
the campus he's doing
things a little bit differently now he's
not having i was told sources told me
he has not brought along his personal
chef his personal masseuse
nor has he brought over his extended
security team
he wants to make sure that he's going
through all the rigors of his teammates
on this campus
to make sure he's blending in and going
through everything that they're
experiencing
and lebron james anthony davis quinn
cook
at times i've seen them roaming the
campus just walking along
just getting a bonding period but lebron
james was clearly
trying to send a message that we're all
in this together
and that is one of his forms of trying
to show that
he's out there with them doing the same
thing that they're doing
and he's eating the same exact chris
haynes
hey you know what that chicken lebron's
eating it too chris appreciate you man
thank you so much
uh keep killing it down